thank you previously on for showing us
that we should expect an unfetched night
rest random shot of spider droid thingy
is random until of course someone in the
comments explains to me politely how
meaningful it is to the overall story it
might even spin a web of evidence to
support their claim i'll leave quiet
only i was concerned that you would feel
insulted why would i feel insulted zero
clue but i don't know how we'd even know
if you were temura morrison has the
exact same facial expression with every
line he delivers after the sale
there was a power vacuum bib fortuna
assumed jabber's mantle this entire
scene is helpful so helpful in fact that
one would assume the debrief would have
happened long before now also is the
names bib mos espa trained oceans
aqualish platoonians and shays are
thrown out i realize that we've been too
hard on movies like raya and the last
dragon sure spelling all their
exposition out with pretty visuals was
annoying at the time but i much prefer
that to this absolute mind-boggling
storm happening in my brain they have a
visual map right there make it light up
or something add a banner with district
symbols that match up to the names show
me a hologram face for [ __ ] sake mayor
has no power he certainly does he has
the wavy hand sweet talking court jester
a receptionist a waiting room an entire
building and a throne room that is at
the very least some level of influence i
guess they're not even trying to make it
appear that the rancor pit is below the
greats in the floor you can see the sand
directly below the decorative pretend
tiles i am north appeal i am a water
monger in the workers district i give
all the sins back if we were to discover
that lortha is a long-lost relative of
jimmy james and newsradio is in fact in
the star wars universe this is the first
i'm hearing of it considering today is
also the first day you were debriefed
about the power vacuum this is not
surprising rid the streets of mozaspa of
this
scourge and i will double my tribute to
you bribery you better fight as good as
you talk dang
i don't know right that's a terrible way
to hire someone hey you talk sassy and
look badassy so i'm gonna hire you
without knowing anything about your
actual skill set wait
how did the water guy even hear fed from
all the way over there in the first
place if you're gonna have all these
multicolored most vespas these things
better voltron or mighty morphin before
this episode is over if not i'm giving
it 50 cents
[Music]
the circle of life
also creatures belching is never funny i
mean unless it is but here it's not we
now return you to the liquid submersion
sleepy bubble chamber of exposition
where dreams are already in progress i
am so annoyed by this clip that i
continue to see and yet do not
understand its significance i'm gonna
assume they never properly tell me why
this moment is so important and i'll
give a few sins now i'll then forget to
give them back later because well sin
count doesn't actually matter unlike
plot points that we've seen many times
that clearly do and should have been
explained by now
well that's just depressing also putting
your hand on the window which causes
hand prints which then need to be
cleaned i just want to say that if you
think this banth is on for some time
just hold tight because they actually
show fett walk back across the desert
too also since the tuscan have several
speeder bikes now as seen in the
previous episode why isn't boba riding
one of those instead of this slow-moving
bantha this miles long bantha hair
hanging off the end of fett's weaponry
yes it's a sin i have business with the
pike syndicate
awesome does boba know what the guard
said to him or is he just guessing from
the look on boba's face i lean the
ladder so why is he just walking on in
the guard could have said you'll need to
drink my piss first and saltine crackers
do not get that taste out of your mouth
no matter what your friends might tell
you they're so i've heard please come in
and of course this one speaks english
even though the guard didn't because
star wars reasons the sands have
belonged to the tuscan since the oceans
dried and those same tuscans boba fetted
his ass all across the sands that they
owned for days with no water and just
weeks later boba's doing their bidding
does that sound like the boba fett we
saw in two scenes in the original
trilogy i think not show does not
contain a pre-show warning of no banthas
were harmed during the filming of this
episode guess i won't be needing this
anymore also it sure is lucky for us
that bob is having these dreams of
memories in the actual order that the
events occurred ah sudden not chewbacca
and yeah yeah i know he has a name it's
ted no weird name to give a wookie you
think they come up with something fun
like chrysanthemum missed opportunity if
you ask me i've never been lifted off my
feet by an enraged wookie but if i were
i'd jab my thumbs into its eye sockets
instead of slapping its thick skull head
go for the soft spots also these two are
making a lot of noise the gladiake is
roaring fed is grunting the regeneration
chamber was opened far too early and
must have sounded an alarm of some kind
and yet no one comes until the in the
nick of time cliche has been activated
this incredibly over flexed big toe
i don't want to be surprised that the
wiki is standing on the perfect spot to
drop into the rancor pit i really do but
i'm not no one is and that is a sin
wasn't it so kind of fat to fetch his
robe before coming down the stairs to
continue to fight off a wookie one might
think he'd also bring a weapon but no
just a robe and a grimace is all fett
needs to command putting your feet on
the table enough food you haven't said
that already i need to respond you need
to get the street kids in here to enjoy
this massive table of food man danny
trejo's cameo appearances just keep
getting weirder and weirder
another twist in turn and who has rights
to what territory oh do go on well i
research when we get back to the far
better bee plot i offer him back if you
renounce all claims to jabba's legacy on
tatooine but
but didn't they just do that
[Music]
but but didn't they just give a rancor
rancor are emotionally complex creatures
emotions you say skip they can become
very loving loving you say skip wait
we're still in this scene this rancor is
on for some time i've written beast 10
times its size wow that's no way to talk
about your exes i'm not sure how this
gun in her thigh is any more
intimidating than the massive gun on her
back
heavy-handed don't you think the two of
you walked in here all armored up and
once again boba has a [ __ ] gun
heavy-handed was how they entered the
room
it's very hard to take this crayola
crayon kid gang seriously on their
chrome power ranger bikes that only go
15 miles per hour this reminds me of a
joke why didn't the droid cross the road
he didn't have the guts
[Laughter]
[Music]
imagine there being a writer that thinks
of this when they think of star wars and
then imagine someone else giving said
writer a lot of money to work on the
book of boba fett i mean there's zero
reason they would know this in advance
but i still feel like the show missed an
opportunity by not giving sophie
thatcher the yellow speed bike along
with a yellow jacket there's gany
he's working with the pikes i mean of
course he is makes perfect sense that
the exact same group boba's been
dreaming about is who is teaming up with
the mayor to take him down not a
coincidence at all that's just how life
and dreams work but where's my mighty
morphin voltron i want a mighty morphin
voltron
why don't you let me get a sip for 15
and here you see the businesses that
were under the protection of
the name that should not be spoken you
can say jabba we do not speak his name
you want me to ask around i don't know
what the hell you're talking about lucy
and i want you to shut up state your
name and your business but mr lemberg
told me to talk to payroll and then
payroll told me to talk to mr lumberg
and i still haven't received my paycheck
and he took my stapler
that's gonna leave a mark
[Music]
don't work on water